so till you started your company when
you were an undergraduate you were at
Columbia and you started catering right
yeah well when I when I moved to New
York to go to school I was really really
into food and what my last year a family
who I babysat for knew that I was really
into it and asked me to come over once a
week and like just make a bunch of stuff
that they could have in their fridge so
I started doing that and kind of like
one thing led to another and by the time
I graduated I was doing that for four
families
Wow so you cook for like the whole week
exactly so I would go over their
groceries in hand and make like eight
dishes that they could kind of just like
mix and match and that's exactly what my
service does now so it was your service
for those who don't know it's called
it's called the colony stat so it's a
weekly home chef service and it truly
grew out of like this very very organic
need and you is you're not no you I'm
sure you're a fantastic chef but you're
not the only one now among the qualities
that you have a whole group of colonies
out there I don't I don't cook for
clients right anymore unless unless they
really or not unless like Steve Martin
cause I'm definitely cooking for you but
no I have about six chefs in New York
for in LA and three in Chicago and how
long did the company start I started it
in oh six Wow so you've gone on five
years you've cut it you've made it to
simulate made it over a hump but you
also travel a lot write your first
cookbook you wrote in Madagascar and
before the movie came out I soon
discovered the island and so so for
people who don't know and I couldn't
guess what the cuisine of Madagascar is
like what what what it sort of is it
well it Scott it's a blend of what the
of what the people are so it's sort of
half Indian and half African which makes
for like sort of African techniques of
you know of drying and frying and that
sort of thing but using Indian spices so
it's really cool because I was actually
in India this year writing another
cookbook and I got to see things that I
saw and I think where were you in India
I was in Tamil Nadu okay we're trying
it's sort of like South South Eastern
okay
in a very small town called care cootie
but I was watching them and learning
about Indian cuisine and thinking oh
that's just like they do in Madagascar
so I learned the opposite way like I
learned the influence before I learned
the origin but it's really amazing to
see how they're connected and you have
yet another book come out called party
like a colonies though which is it what
does that mean can i party like a colony
stirred so smushed in between one coffee
Asuka foe which is my Malaga cookbook
and the Indian cookbook that will be out
sometime next year called the Bangla
table I just came out with a book called
party like a colonies debt which has
nothing to do with travel it just has to
do with enjoying yourself throwing a
party not stressing out about it
bringing people together through food
which is kind of like what I'm all about
making slightly healthier recipes that
are seeking party like the colonies and
still lose weight yeah exactly I mean
it's like I want you to have a girl like
great food at your party but then still
be able to go dancing afterwards now if
you do all these sorts of things you
also do some television and what do you
if you wake up in the morning what do
you say Jill I am an entrepreneur I am a
writer I am a travel cookbook writer I
am a television personality what what
are you all these I think I am all of
them I mean I try to stay connected to
to really this idea of creating
connection and creating togetherness and
currently that's through food you know
whether it's getting the word out in an
article or getting the word out by
having a spot on a television show it's
really all about this idea of creating
connectedness and really bringing people
together so Danny Meyer's said something
very nice about you and I'd love to hear
your reaction he said you're the next
Martha Stewart that is very nice that
and I'm honored I'm absolutely on it and
there are some strange parallels there
are some strange perils we both kind of
modeled our way through high school and
we both went to Barnard and we both
started our empires shall I say with the
catering company you can say Empire I
think yeah I mean she's amazing mrs.
Forbes you should have an empire
right exactly it might be time but it's
really you know I just split time
between New York and LA very good
bicoastal
and so would you consider yourself at
this point a success have you made it
are you still striving or well I'm
always still striving but like this is
such a non forms answer but I really
define success by happiness you know why
is that non Forbes easy money is
happiness is initial my name can help
you with happiness but I mean I really
believe in like you know whatever the
connection is to to sort of yourself and
how kind of how much in the flow of the
universe you are that kind of determines
your happiness this could all go away
tomorrow and I hope that I would still
be you know a happy person I kind of
doubt that it will thank you so much
sure thank you